[Music]
let's go to kansas city missouri where
earl is waiting earl how can we help
thanks for taking my call basically
the question is this i'm a minister
and i work in a non-profit organization
um
my question has to do with this
you guys have a have an ethos there in
in your
with ramsey solutions i have a christian
culture because i i hear you guys use a
lot of phrases and whatnot so i can use
some language that
so when i say a servant chart you know
exactly what i'm talking about
my question has to do with
what is the relationship of any
between having a servant's heart and say
not receiving a promotion that you
thought or you should have received
or being demoted
from the position that you're in
if your employer says yeah this is this
is what happened but you need to have a
servant chart about this
how exactly
is that processed within
that mode of thinking where are the
lines how does that fit together so you
know so you were demoted in a on a
church staff and and and they said you
need to handle this with a servant's
heart is that what i'm hearing
i'm i'm about possibly to be demoted
yeah so i'm just
i'm just trying why are you being
demoted information
why um
changes in administration above me
but but why are you being demoted
other than changes with folks above me i
don't know i'm not exactly sure i mean
is it is it are they cutting back
discipleship i'm sorry is it cutting
back on cost are they trying to uh
they're going in a different leadership
direction they don't you're not um
performing it to the standards that they
want it's saying a new a new leadership
team came in
there's more to it than that right and
be honest
what happened was
basically an administrator
um one position above me
put forth a promotion
for me
to do a different job okay so right now
i run a whole
i run a whole program for men okay
if i was to take this if i was to be put
in this position i would only
i would like to do one third of the work
that i that i was doing before i'm
trying to be vague just in case okay i
got it um so it's not a matter of my
performance i can assure you of that uh
but this one person
put forth this
uh this idea that well we can put this
person here
and then we can have four people doing
case management
because right now i just don't do case
management i do everything i
teach a ton of classes i do so many
different things so but are you being
asked to do more work for less money or
are they just edging you out i'm i'm
confused at
what's happening i was trying not to be
too specific okay because because the
time constraint okay well
okay go ahead
so so basically
there's a different program where
clients go to
for nine months after my program my
program is six weeks long
basically i assess
what caused the homelessness usually
it's addictions or mental disorders or a
combination of both or other things then
for the next weeks uh next six weeks i
take care of
discipling them telling them about
christ teaching having them classes
classes on addiction classes on many
many different things okay i help them
get all the things they need to be
prepared for the next so is is the
church saying that we don't want to do
those things anymore
no the church is saying we want to take
your program and the next program and
put them together okay so you no longer
will run this program but you'll be a
case manager right in the middle there
you go okay all right so right now i run
the whole program right so earl here's
here's my take on your your initial
question
john you weigh in here but earl
uh it feels manipulative to to me to
that's christian ease i grew up in the
church so i feel like i can say this um
you can have a servant's heart you
should have a servant's heart we should
all have a servant's heart okay
but you still have a heart
and this is an emotion and you don't
like it and it's obvious and you don't
have to like it now what you have to
decide though is
they've made this decision sounds like
it's being made
um and i've got to decide
can i serve there
can i get my head and heart right after
i deal with this disappointment and do i
feel like i'm supposed to be there do i
feel called to this particular place
versus i know the work that i love to do
and what i'm called to do so i don't
like the way it sounds uh because the
bottom line is this feels kind of crappy
and
you're gonna have to decide do i wanna
stay here because of this now don't
leave because you're hurt i think you
need to leave if you feel like
the work i'm supposed to be doing the
work that i'm challenged by i'm not able
to do here anymore so i'm gonna look
elsewhere but to answer your question at
its simplest form
how do you process that um
you can have a servant's heart and still
think it's pretty crappy
you'll have to act like a jerk yeah be
heartbroken and be angry and pissed off
and frustrated the servant's heart part
yeah and i agree with you phil it's
manipulative that's just nonsense yeah
it's manipulative nonsense i hate that
crap um
the reality is though you can have all
those feelings and experiences you still
have an obligation to treat people with
dignity and respect that's right and you
still have to deal with reality yeah and
the reality is you worked really hard
this was your baby you loved it and
a new group of managers came in and said
we're gonna we're gonna contract
everything together and move into a
different role and so heartbreaking it's
hard sad it feels personal it's gonna be
vulnerability shame all stuff
and you're gonna say
uh i appreciate you being honest with me
and telling me that and i've got some
decisions to make that's right yeah more
complex than that but it's not it is
don't blow up the bridge but you know
the
you don't have to not say you know or
push back and if there is some and if
and and i
i'm reading into this john i am too i've
been there too i hate okay but
if the decision has yet to be made and
if they were just going you need to
handle this with a servant's heart and
they're going don't push back well don't
ask questions you can ask questions and
you should you can still have a humble
spirit and you can be civil
and ask questions and push back but it
just felt like to me it was a blanket
statement yeah that was just like hey
dude here's the deal yeah you don't get
any say in this
um which i understand leaders have to
make decisions but to put up don't know
jesus
when you make a business decision in a
non-profit and then you wrap people's
human reaction and make it a moral or
spiritual issue
drives me crazy because it's weaponizing
yes thank you it's weaponizing kindness
it's weaponizing the gospel it's
weaponizing um humanity don't do that if
you're gonna make a business decision
look at somebody and say you've worked
really hard and we appreciate it we're
going a different true and let me just
throw a shot at leaders out there don't
you dare whether it's a faith-based
organization or not don't you dare
treat people like crap and wrap it in
the flag of the cause so stupid
it's not she got me all fired up here
earl thinks i was having a great
wednesday and then earl calls now i'm
glad you called man thanks a lot yeah
earl you'll get through this man do not
let this decision in any way define you
and treat people with dignity and
respect brother no matter what happens